It sounds like an urban legend, but
actor Jim Caviezel was legitimately
struck by lightning on the set of
"The Passion of the Christ."
Andthat's just one of the setbacks
the actor faced during filming.
Jim Caviezel is lighting up Hollywood
with his leading role as Tim Ballard in
"Sound of Freedom." Fans of the movie
who haven't kept up with the actor's
career may not remember that Caviezel got
lit up himself while shooting a different
movie nearly twenty years ago, and
luckily survived to tell the tale.
In director Mel Gibson's controversial but highly
successful 2004 film "The Passion of the Christ,"
Caviezel took on arguably his biggest role as
Jesus. During filming, the actor's experience
was fraught with peril, including quite
literally being struck by lightning.
In 2003, well into the production of "The Passion
of the Christ," Entertainment Weekly reported on
the lightning strike that occurred while filming
a scene. Caviezel wasn't the only one hit,
either. Assistant director Jan Michelini was also
struck by the bolt, marking the second time that
he had been hit by lightning while working on the
movie. Producer Steve McEveety told the outlet,
"I'm about a hundred feet away from them,
when I glance over and see lightning coming out
of Caviezel's ears. Both Caviezel and Michelini
got struck. The main bolt hit Caviezel and
one of its forks hit Michelini's umbrella."
"When I was hit, everybody fell on their face.
The ground shook. That was
the last shot of the movie."
Both Caviezel and Michelini survived
the lightning strike and later reports
claimed they were unharmed by the incident. But
that's not the complete truth. In an interview
with Peggy Noonan of The Words Group, Caviezel
described what the experience felt like. He said,
"About four seconds before it happened it
was quiet, and then it was like someone
slapped my ears. I had seven or eight
seconds of, like, a pink, fuzzy color,
and people started screaming. They said I
had fire on the left side of my head and
light around my body. All I can tell you is that
I looked like I went to Don King's hairstylist."
Between the lightning and numerous other injuries
sustained during the production, the actor ended
up in the operating room twice for serious
medical procedures. He told Catholic Courier,
"It nearly killed me. Not many people get struck
by lightning; I did. Five and a half months of
cold. I had to have two heart surgeries, including
open-heart surgery, because of that film."
The lightning strike is just one item on the
laundry list of injuries Caviezel ended up with
throughout the production of "The Passion of the
Christ." In one instance, he sustained a deep gash
in his back as the result of an accident
in a scene where Jesus is being whipped.
Caviezel told "Today" that another
actor missed the board protecting
him and accidentally struck his back
with their whip. Caviezel recalled,
"I turned around and looked at the guy,
and I tell you, I may be playing Jesus,
but I felt like Satan at that moment. I turned to
him, a couple of expletives came out of my mouth."
He would later get struck in the back again,
which left him with a 14-inch gash that
would eventually turn into a lasting scar.
Caviezel also dislocated his shoulder
while carrying a large cross and caught
pneumonia because of filming in frigid
temperatures for extended periods of
time. Despite all of the ways the
movie damaged the actor's body,
Caviezel maintains that he doesn't regret
working on the project. He told Catholic Courier,
"If we had shot that film in a
studio, you wouldn't have seen
that performance. Was it worth it? Absolutely."